the jurgen experience i'll take my
chances
[Music]
take my chance with coronavirus next
part which i've heard i'm not to get the
conspiracy on this part but like
i've heard nano getting added to rna and
vaccine stuff now oh
the nano chips that's the pro that's a
problem bill gates
yeah right you got a gate you got a nano
robot but
i don't know what's accurate or what's
not accurate boy nobody took a bigger
hit during this coronavirus
lockdown than bill gates well he became
a villain
i don't think he's a villain but i also
think that listen we're living in a time
now
of batman era villain like where like
these guys have
billions and billions and trillions of
dollars i don't think he's a villain i'm
not saying he's a villain i don't think
he's a villain i'm not i'm not saying
he's gonna listen but here's what's
[ __ ]
bill gates has done more for humanity
than most rich people would ever imagine
doing that guys built schools and wells
and helped people get educated
dave look him and his his wife the the
the gates foundation
they've done a tremendous amount of
positive work but
what i'm saying is i have but he's
wading into the controversial waters of
the vaccine so listen but what i'm
saying is
that during this pandemic he's become a
villain for the first time ever
and he's like 70 because he wants to
deliver people the mark of the beast
that's all that's the only reason people
are upset with him is he wants to
deliver people the mark of the beast
but listen when he go listen you got to
expect a certain amount of uh
a certain amount of you know discussion
when you're making
when you are the guy inserting yourself
into this very kind of volatile debate
about public health and you're telling
people they need to
have be vaccinated to travel and and
these are the standards that you want
people to adapt
listen man he could have just been a
billionaire that was swam in his [ __ ]
pool
why do you think he talked about that
like telling people that they need to be
vaccinated
he i guess he if you give him the
benefit of the daddy's wants to help
people i guess that's not give him the
benefit of doubt
okay if we don't give him the benefit of
the doubt we'll say that he
wants the world to look exactly like he
thinks there's necessary and unnecessary
things
he thinks that he should be in charge of
people's health public health
or that he thinks that a group of
scientists or him and his foundation
should be in charge of public health um
his found really
no i mean listen there's also billions
and trillions of dollars to be made off
some of these vaccines
does he is he making money off vaccines
i don't know what he's doing but he has
so much money why does he need more
money
why does anyone need more money i don't
think he's doing it for money i'm not
saying he's evil guy
i'm saying that we cannot write a blank
check i feel like he's saying he's an
evil guy
we cannot write a blank check on anybody
we can't write a blank check joe to
anyone
look at him the next app that's in 2015.
that's when he planned it listen i don't
trust anybody who wears an outfit
this [ __ ] sweater with this this
can't say this and i'm being totally
serious
the button shirt underneath him and dr
fauci created aids
that's all i'll say
that's all i just said why because you
know
people people walk around just for fun
and they created age so that's the only
reason i'm a little skeptical no but in
all seriousness
our society shouldn't be structured
where one guy stands up because by the
way uh in order to travel and go places
and open your businesses here's what you
need to do
and we talked about that in the
beginning of the show but the government
doing it why is it better for private
billionaires doing it but here's the
thing like why are we listening to him
talk about public health issues like
yuck
he's the guy who founded microsoft
phenomenal question yeah i mean that's a
great question
is it just because he's rich he's
interested what if i stepped up
and started telling everyone it's time
to get vaccinated everyone's got to get
vaccinated yeah people be like hey hey
hey relax you're a [ __ ] comedian in a
cage fighting commentary right
why are you telling everybody why don't
you tell people to vote
why is he doing it well that's why
people are a little suspicious
he's stepping out of his lane now it's
that sweater with the shirt the sweater
the creating of aids and mark of the
beast all of it's a prop
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love me